alors c'est pour ça que je suis là
l'image est symbolique trois candidats
et une chaise vide c'était lors du
dernier débat local dans la
circonscription de Camille lorrain
marie-evencourt de Québec solidaire
venait de se retirer de la course parce
qu'elle avait un peu plus tôt retirée un
dépliant du Parti québécois d'une boîte
aux lettres un revirement digne d'une
surprise d'octobre comme on les appelle
dans les campagnes présidentielles
américaines selon cette électrique qui a
finalement voté PQ
complètement inattendue qui change
complètement la donne chez nous je pense
que Monsieur Campo doit se sentir moins
sécure
en 2018 il avait arraché cette
circonscription aux parties québécois
par 500 voix sur 50000 électeurs
aujourd'hui avec une candidate de moins
sur l'échiquier et des électeurs devenus
orphelins à moins d'une semaine du
scrutin pour moi ça change pas grand
chose on continue à rencontrer les gens
individuellement faire du porte-à-porte
rien prendre pour acquis car on trouve
de coucher les électeurs solidaires je
vais réfléchir encore est-ce que je ne
sauterai plus parce que quand même on
est déçu ben je dirais je garderai le
même
l'ancien
le transferts vers la CAQ donc mais
aussi je sais que la politique c'est
peut-être pas toujours
mais j'aime pas ça une attitude comme ça
donc j'ai décidé de
voter pour le pique
et des glissements vers Paul
Saint-Pierre platmond donc qui pourrait
bénéficier d'une prime au chef je suis
un électeur de la CAQ si c'était pas PSP
je vois très pour la carte on veut PSP
dans le comté on va ramener les seuils
en proportion de notre capacité
d'accueil est-ce qu'ils sont un
frémissement en sa faveur lui dont les
performances au débats ont été soulignés
mais je pense que les gens ont suivi ont
suivi les débats sont intéressés quand
je marche dans le comté les gens
interviennent baissent leur fenêtres
font des saluts ça klaxonne la candidate
libérale elle aussi pourrait profiter
report de voix des solidaires j'ai
toujours parlé de justice sociale du
communautaire de la place communautaire
et comment l'économie et le
communautaire les deux sont reliés et
non c'est pas en opposition
dans un secteur qui s'embourgeoisent et
où les logements se font plus rares et
chers surtout pour les familles les
électeurs s'attendent à des résultats à
l'échelle de la province la CAQ prévoit
construire 12000 logements sociaux c'est
50 000 pour Québec solidaires et le
Parti libéral 35000 pour le PQ il y a
des gens qui presse à demander pourquoi
12000 pourquoi pas 50000 il y a une
question de capacité de construire on
nous dit du côté de la kaki des bâtir il
y a pas de main d'oeuvre mais c'est
drôle pour un troisième lien Québec ça
par contre il semble y en avoir de la
main d'oeuvre
le ou la prochaine élu devra aussi faire
passer le test d'acceptabilité sociale
au futur reine de l'Est qui traversera
la circonscription ce sera après le test
des urnes qui sera l'un des plus
palpitant à suivre
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal